hello i'm conan o'brien
i purchased this jacket online from a
north korean magician and seeing it now
on camera i regret it
up until this moment your life has had
little meaning but i'm here to change
all that
because i'm here to present
the incredible team coco tablet app
i hope you're ready for the future
because the future is sure ready for the
you
we'll fix that you'll get better
the team coco tablet app is a new way to
watch conan on two screens one tv and
one tablet
monday through thursday at 11 pm just
fire up the team coco tablet app while
watching conan on tbs sit back and let
the team coco techno magic start
delivering exclusive content and
conversation in sync with the show
you're watching
by the way
anytime anyone says techno magic i make
money
techno magic
techno magic techno you can interact
with friends and other fans while behind
the scenes photos trivia and more appear
right at your fingertips you can also go
back to previous items it's as easy as
scrolling through the timeline
this app has access to time travel
portals nasa doesn't want you to know
about it that's that's uh i know it's
not on the cards leave it in
leave it in
you'll see dinosaurs
remember you can use the team coco
tablet app with any recent episode of
conan whether you're watching live on
your dvr or even on a full streaming
episode within the app itself
i smell innovation
and
onion mustard did someone make a
sandwich
on this the team coco tablet app also
has all the on-demand conan video clips
slideshows and blog updates you could
ever want
there you have it the team coco
tablet app
it's better than you
[Music]